good morning believe nation today's
message is have a well-thought-out plan
now over to you Paul Rodriguez I
consider myself a cautious person that's
why I wouldn't just decide like that on
any business matter so for me with
primitive it wasn't like someone just on
a whim investment I didn't just jump in
like I'm gonna open up a store make a
lot of money obviously you want all
those cool things to happen but you got
it really have an idea of where you want
to take your project you know you just
have to have well-thought-out plan so
that way you minimize your risk and find
yourself successful more often than not
so what do you think I think plans are
great but a lot of time those plans
deviate in a direction we might not
think they would for example I wanted to
be a political reporter as a Canadian in
the States I didn't know the difference
between the house and the Senate on the
first day of my job I was late I dropped
the laptop and hit a prominent
politician with shrapnel from my device
I was fired the next day my plan
completely took a turn and well it's
great if you have passion I think you
also need to be realistic about what
that plan could be in the different
directions it could take we all have
different aptitudes mine was definitely
not part of the plan i thought i had i
think there are people who love the plan
and don't do enough time actually doing
and then a lot of people who love to do
but don't take enough time planning and
whichever when you are you need to spend
enough time doing the other thing i
remember when i had my first business we
did a lot of planners and a whole summer
planning perfect like perfect playing
like i need to write my business plan
everybody tells you to write the
business plan and then as soon as we
started getting out to the market
realize that a lot of the assumptions
that we made were wrong and we need to
actually you know take feedback and
continue to improve our plane and so I
think the people who desperately love
having a plan you'll never write the
perfect plan the plan will always change
to Matt's point right it's going to
change something will happen new
feedback will come you will change and
want to go in different directions but
the people who just do and don't have
any structure the plant helps so I think
it's a combination you need to have
plan but you need to have the
flexibility to adopt the plane because I
think too many entrepreneurs just stay
on the same plan to and then that's a
recipe for boredom and mediocrity and
then you never change and continue to
grow as you grow as an entrepreneur
agree that balance for me the plan wrote
me which was why I failed you had the
plan and then adapted and I think that's
what I should have done in the first
place so the question of the day today
is if you've had a plan what was the
biggest obstacle or the person that
completely through your plan off who the
person a through your plan off I like it
leave in the comments below we're going
to join a discussion thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and they'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso